louder with Crowder studios protected
exclusively by Walter and hopper
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you know I was doing the mr. Olympia
most muscular pose and I hit my finger
now on the on the mute button and then I
remembered that I have a mute button you
forgot about it I completely forgot
about it you know you can't hear me good
job but it's not so bad because we don't
have a Gerald today with us okay we have
full on the show today and for those who
are not members of my club then we have
an extended like 30 minutes behind me
well because we came back with a stuff
on YouTube question of the day before
introduce everyone else I used to dig
Taylor Swift was a fan I'm done I don't
know it's still that way also be honest
how much do you really know about the
Equality Act and do you support it
because it's something that's been
talked about quite a bit
seems most people don't know there's
some from their Weiner uh before we get
the news of the day my half-asian Lerner
bill Richman is here how are you sir a
lot of good feedback let him know you
love him because a lot of people hey I'm
glad that he's in the he's in third
chair there we have quarterblack Sheeran
song she's also a boy that you're not a
doctor you're only a lawyer quit pest
got it good dog
and replacing jail because it's back
surgery when you successfully is Gerald
to be today so good thank you yeah there
we go he's got the line of the day a
spitting image Vogel that shows up on
our accounting sheet as Britney yeah
that's all it's not a joke and I'll have
a receipt for Britain's more words in
there but we can't say them yes there
are more words from there it's very
uncomfortable sending your mother to
purchase those alright we're gonna be
talking about the Equality Act Taylor
Swift of course but top story before any
of that Bernie Sanders this week praised
China you know them China's leadership
in a recent interview Bernie this comes
from Washington Examiner Bernie said
that China and its leadership have made
more progress in addressing extreme
poverty than any country in the history
of civilization and have done a lot of
things for their people obviously a lot
of outrage the Manhattan Institute
think-tank issued the following rebuttal
don't trust China you know it's it's
it's pretty easy when you go from what
we're just gonna murder a hundred
thousand less people here you know okay
let's meet this is important the
definition of extreme poverty here we're
talking about is less than two dollars a
day okay so when he's talking about
China bringing them out of that but it's
it's about I think it was 88 percent and
now it's point seven percent so there
section by the way this was in 81 I
don't have the exact numbers now and
this thing this is 2015 I think we're
the over layout from Forbes so the
reduction in poverty in China is based
or it directly correlates to them
opening up their markets even though
it's not really a free-market economy
anymore still not still not free but
freer free / yes so they're still now
their point 7 for extreme poverty in the
US it's about point 1 but keep in mind
the average salary in China the average
income is $12,000 not even close to half
that of the United well and this is the
same government that is now persecuting
persecuting Christians and locking out
pastors for just undermining the
government you guys have done a ton for
their people yes well it made sense
right so they gave more jobs to the poor
and said hey as a condition of coming
out of extreme poverty you must crush
all civil liberties right so new rule
book you can make sneaker yeah but I
have no Bible was that agent bill maher
Bible go make your Nikes they wouldn't I
always feel like Asians will make the
worst spies Chinese well baloney
well they're bad I call no sy you mean
no one would hire an Asian to be a spy
which is why we would be great at it you
store your personal photos in the crowd
I don't know why here a trenchcoat
apparently Bibles in their trenches
figure with political news Washington DC
woman is now claiming that Ilhan Omar
stole her husband comes from New York
Post according to divorce papers a
cheating spouse told her he was having
an affair with the congresswoman then
made a shocking declaration of love for
Omar before he ditched his current wife
this was trending everywhere when
reached for Congress for comment the
congresswoman responded hey he was my
brother first little on the nose but
warranted think how unlikable must his
wife have been I wanna
Omar realize me I think there's a
misinterpretation it wasn't it was those
were tears of sadness they were tears of
joy yes by the way did you know she is
like 20
moving not moving traffic violations
parking tickets that 22 I think since
2009 major and she still has a license
but do you have more than that first
part I don't know anyone mean he's Asian
no traffic violations probably not
depends well I thought I was very
surprised when I saw it listen if people
come to our country they should respect
our laws or go back to the shitholes hey
this is a great story I will not go back
to Chicago toy company Hasbro they now
own Death Row Records so the corporation
know from you know mr. Potato Head the
Power Rangers toy line announced that
they will join forces with the label
most known for West Coast very important
to note West Coast gangster ass the
company is attempting a brand rollout
actually by Christmas now with the new
Suge Knight Ruxpin little Cooper black
he had a rough day at school he said
none of the kids would talked I have an
idea the police didn't do it their
podcast
[Music]
good night Suge Knight Ruxpin you'll be
my best friend forever nobody
Suge Knight Ruxpin batteries and dr.
Dre's masters sold separately looks like
Suge Knight I know my people I have no
idea that we had that kind of production
guys it could be Chinese with that kind
of tailoring it thank you we also bound
its feet I've always said this like when
I retire land I don't do this show
anymore I want to be the Suge Knight
without the felonies love conservative
media I want to be the guy who can help
support other conservatives you know how
if you have good shows that you want to
pitch you don't actually will end up
producing and maybe I'll hang Vanilla
Ice over a balcony
we all aspire to that everybody Oh
Suge Knight continuing with music
related news the MTV Music Video Awards
for this week
which we'll get to obviously constellar
so it's a little later in the Equality
Act but former NSYNC member Lance Bass
showed up in a pink tuxedo call me crazy
but I'm starting to think Lance Bass is
gay so this was interesting there's a
story about fake news is said to create
fake memories this was a new study comes
from psych central according to the
Ireland study people can form false
memories after seeing fake news stories
especially if those stories align with
their political beliefs wait wait so
you're telling me that I didn't have sex
with that black oh no you definitely had
sex with bad boy yeah you had sex with
bad boy there's no debt this is what
we're talking more like political
memories might be tainted by the brush
of time yeah you don't get do-overs on
that one this next one we were right in
this bit we couldn't get away from it
sounding like noir MacDonald in our head
so we're gonna do this as a norm ik
Donald joke alright here only alright so
today is a birthday of you know both
Michael Jackson and Ingrid Bergman one
captured the hearts of millions in her
portrayal of is Holland in the classic
film Casablanca film some have called
the apex of cinema the other was a
homosexual pedophile so you know like to
have sex with kids name a wild turkey
101 you know I can't get enough of wild
turkey 101 apparently by the way there's
a new blood sucking leech that's been
identified in DC area swamps all the
news that's fit to not even print talk
it's a slow news week I mean come on the
whole spectrum this comes from when you
know it comes from a local Fox affiliate
it's a slow news week it's comes from
Fox 5 DC the scientist who delivered a
species said that the leech is not
something new that's come up but it's
been there the whole time
unrecognized which I'm told is actually
the subject of this season's premiere of
River Monsters our nation's capital so
you got yeah
it's the horrifying Booker s lampur anus
made its way in through a lake champlain
I think and then the Great Lakes
speaking of
let's turn to the Pacific Northwest did
you have anything what do you think
there Gerald B yeah as usual well said
astute turning to the Pacific Northwest
a million dollars of cocaine was found
hidden in bananas police uncovered 45
grams of cocaine in three different
Washington supermarkets all hidden in
different kinds of boxes of bananas at
Oakland yeah we really should have
suspected it considering Curious
George's most recent outing George eats
a human face
so that was for people listening to
results you know the guy who ate the
face of Miami bath salts he only tested
positive for marijuana a lot of people
don't know that I'm not saying marijuana
makes a face but I think he was a
paranoid schizophrenic and then you know
a little bit of a little bit of Tahoe og
pushed him over the edge a little bit of
a little bit of a platinum og a little
bit of Blue Dream
a little bit of Skywalker cush a little
bit of knowledgeable on this purple
stripe og like this strain this strain
will help you sleep in this strain helps
cure cancer what does this train do this
train makes you really energetic and
focused with what are they they're both
pot that's what all right ones from this
greenhouse ones from this greenhouse
which one makes me not eat a face you
know it's a crapshoot once it leaves the
green you'll know it you'll know after
you try ya know after as you end up in
the clink on NASA astronaut by the way
been accused of stealing her estranged
wife's identity from space good job so
New York Pro she's accused of improperly
accessing the west bank account while on
the International Space Station so one
small step for man one giant leap for
lesbian space criminals the men's right
sort of sexist they're going to use this
forever men have been going up to space
forever no real problems drama-free war
woman goes up identity fraud immediately
there's only another women in space that
have committed crimes
yes all crime in space 100% namely the
crime of taking up the seat where a man
could have been finally it's just not
well documented the woman-on-woman crime
the worst thing is you know we say this
and obviously were being sarcastic
comments sections the Dutch right yes no
women in space have over say guys guys
there he's like delete delete delete
Lee was already typing women can go and
spaces passengers I just don't believe
in female pilots that's all I believe in
female pilots I don't they believe they
exists I know they exist I just okay
should say I don't trust them ask for
directions honey we're just going up I
would let you fly can you end up where
it says in the ticket don't pressure me
and on the make the joke that like man
are too afraid to look at a map yeah but
you know what we end up there and you
call me saying do I turn left at the
McDonald's what
give me a landmark go south I don't know
is that the CVS I don't know what just
go south is Walgreens I'm sorry are you
married we have to bleep that you'll
know finally there's this story where
Andrew yahng yahng gangers out there
hello admits it's having once named his
pectoral muscles he named his right PEC
Rex and his left PEC
let's derivative and apparently in
college he could jostle them on command
to impress the girls if the girls were
impressed he'd then introduced them to
allegedly Wang hung which besides being
racist unfortunately turned out to be a
disappointing exaggeration named is P
what do you think about that should
Knight Ruxpin supposed to hate that's
enough been horrible I'm sorry you have
to sit next to that bill it's fine we're
friends I don't understand why he's not
a black bear though
well build-a-bear was running low on
inventory I do feel as though many many
times when we go we purchase these items
and they ask us what it's for if we gave
him an honest answer they would not
I lie every time that's what we're doing
is just Crowder confronts where you go
and try and buy stuff honestly and
they're like I don't know no joke joke
night no way no way so this is for [ __ ]
night Ruxpin you know I think maybe KB
down the block he's been gone for four
years on rip I don't know yeah that's
your best chance closing now no yes no
really are ya I used to be a Taylor
Swift fan but this is something we're
gonna talk about the Equality Act here
but let's set this up Taylor Swift she
had this VMA performance acceptance
speech where she promoted the Equality
Act and then called out the White House
for not responding to her potato peas
the speech
at the end of this video there was a
petition and there still is a petition
there's four dudes up there Dennis
Rodman
that petition because it now has half a
million signatures which which is
getting cocky she's getting confidence
which is five times the amount that it
would need to wear in a response from
the White House oh look she's got a
little look there that way
snap snap guess what that would mean
anything if everything that she just
said was not factually incorrect so it
brings us to this week's what if he
all right we're gonna talk about it's
always a short look people get just
jarred if you're listening to an audio
sorry but we're gonna the Equality Act
but this whole speech let me do this to
rattle this off first miss Swift you're
not actually wearing a watch right so
when she does the looking at the watch I
understand you're trying to make me look
before you'll just you this was
obviously premeditated put on the watch
second the White House only has to
respond to be submitted petition through
whitehouse.gov
yours was a change.org petition and you
didn't even address it to the White
House you addressed it to the Senate
sweetheart no even though we know that
you've ditched all of your people and
teardrops on your guitar and you're
going for the pop world not to hang out
with people like Lena Dunham you didn't
have to throw your dad under the bus and
have him delete all of his social media
just because he happens to be a
Republican how much makeup you're
wearing these you're looking more and
more like a [ __ ] by the way don't take
my word for it John Travolta was clearly
confused but he sleeps with a lot of
[ __ ] you're surprised every time you
win an award this is like what your 42nd
or does that a Grammy
it's the MTV Award for a music video
which is the most played most popular
video of the year I don't know but you
know what I do have a petition that has
more than five times she had this look
on her face like someone just said all
finished with the abortion miss Swift so
what do you think Gerald be alright
under the Equality Act and why it sucks
this is one of those things that sounds
good right the Equality efforts you set
up the doll by the way I love the crappy
golf shirt you really captured the SS
and gee Morgan Jr by the way is doing
his back surgery went well we do we love
you Gerald just you know get off the
pain pills we don't want me to be like
the DC guy yelling eat my bud this is am
I good the Equality Act just like
pro-choice sounds good the green New
Deal actually it doesn't even really
sound good that does sound a little bit
authoritarian oh you just plan to see
people doing a goose-step when it's the
New Deal but you know I get it the point
is this sounds good and she said the bit
the bill basically means that everyone
gets treated equally
no let me get into the Equality Act and
why it's incredibly dangerous and
corrosive okay the bill prohibits to
quote it exactly discrimination on the
basis of sex gender identity and sexual
orientation
okay I understand discrimination based
on sex I understand sexual orientation
get it key takeaway here there was
gender identity it's not defined at all
in any real way when you look at the
bill so someone can just identify as a
woman and federal law demands that
everyone treat them that way that's a
problem bill do you see some of the
complications that so this is one of the
things people think they go oh well I'm
just gonna put a law into place and
decide it's gonna be zero I want equal
rights I mean obviously that's not what
the rule in that what the law is about
you first said that but when you
actually have to apply it how are you
going to apply something so undefined
and malleable as gender identity I mean
everyone has a problem with just even
understanding okay so if I decide to
change today
if Trump decides he wants to identify as
a woman is it now we have our first
woman president everyone's gonna run to
his backing of course not and yet these
are the types of laws that are supported
that don't actually talk about how
you're actually going to apply it in
real life right they just want to say in
the high level in the clouds and then
when someone goes well I'd actually like
a little bit of structure there to know
how we're gonna follow the law they
start saying don't you know you're not
supposed to hate a female it's wrong to
hey no problem by the way it's not as
though there isn't any precedent for
this because we can see some
complications so how would allowing
anyone to identify however they want
potentially be a problem in other words
why would anyone be opposed to the
Equality Act
no one's opposed to equality that's not
what we're talking about so let's start
with this one reason women sports we've
already covered how transgenderism
destroying women's sports yeah you have
male the female transgender athletes
winning world cycling championships one
in people's well that's an isolated
incident no winning national
championships and weightlifting smashing
for powerlifting world records in a day
and by the way a biological male is now
the number one ranked NCAA women's track
star trans athletics where men get
everything in women get consistent
beatings if the islam of sports also in
a recent meet this is important to note
said transgender was first ranked first
nationally an enemy someone placed
second respectively was also a
transgender for the wreck
the race included exactly two
transgender competitors how many - where
were they ranked number one and two oh
that's hard men just have an
unbelievable advantage testosterone
we've gone through this higher bone
density greater lung capacity higher
ratio fast twitch muscle fibers but we
have to throw this out because someone
wrote a college thesis and Taylor Swift
as an imaginary watch and this is
something important people said well
we're gonna deal with sports when we get
there and this is something I would like
your opinion here on this bill but they
said we can make a provision for sports
actually no you can't if it's the law
sports have to follow the law now they
can add to it in certain ways for
example like a Nevada State Athletic
Commission you see this a lot with UFC
when they had this whole testosterone is
she going on it's legal people can
procure testosterone but this sports
organization can say alright we don't
want to use that because of an unfair
advantage but if a law specifically says
you cannot prohibit in any way someone
who's on testosterone they can't do it
it's not left open-ended here that's the
challenge that I mean it's again when
you get into the actual practical
application of we've talked about this
in the First Amendment if you actually
put a definition of hate speech and then
you try to apply it it falls apart
immediately and in almost every example
it's the same way with trying to define
gender identity and say it's not just
the whatever it's the one effort right
so someone can say well I am you know of
97 thousand different versions
apparently that exists and gender
identity I'm gonna cycle through them
like t-shirts every single day the rest
of the world catch up and if you don't
it's a crime right right it's it you're
liable civilly to have to pay money or
fines or maybe even go to jail or all
those types of things at the very least
to be pilloried in social media if you
can't actually keep up with the changing
fluid gender identities and that's a
problem in the same way when you talk
about discriminating against folks in a
certain way you have to be able to
define what the discrimination is right
and when one of the biggest proponents
of it Taylor Swift can't even define it
I'm loving the music but stick to it
yeah try and go hey you think I should
shut up and sing pretty much pretty much
yeah she's just saying minions yeah you
know let's go with that yes that's not
what that's not why you were hired
that's not why you're here we don't
really care we don't really want even
and by the way you're wrong I mean is it
discrimination to say you know what you
can't do the hormones what's but that's
what
we compete my point exactly by the way
hit the notification bell if you're
subscribed because apparently
subscriptions don't mean a whole lot new
video every day just bookmark the page
check in and of course we have hours and
hours of content at bug Club if you join
up a lot of credit com / my club and
there's a crowd or bits channel on
YouTube they want to see clips and you
want to be able to search them pretty
quickly
another reason here - we talked about
the Equality bill women's only spaces
this is something that has turned a lot
of feminists against others so you know
it's turned lesbian angry sister against
blue haired pseudo lesbian sister and
that's sad bill may only read from there
ill with respect to gender identity an
individual shall not be denied access to
a shared facility including a restroom a
locker room and a dressing room that is
in accordance with the individual's
gender identity at which again is not
defined even without laws like this
there have been tons of cases of sexual
assault rape when male the female
transgenders have been allowed to go
into women's only spaces but I'm not
saying that always happens at every
transgender is a sexual predator but
most reason we had Jessica Yaniv who use
these protections in Canada to try and
gain access to underage nude girls and
we're still trying yes still try going
yeah well I mean is it maybe they're not
all predators but I'm not exactly
mystified at how many of them are sexual
deviants I mean yeah that they pretty
much have their identity focused on
their sexual deviancy or at least their
gender deviancy yeah well they wouldn't
say so yeah exactly gender you can't
choose your sexuality but you can choose
your gender that's your new thing by the
way
show me your tips yeah that's Jessica
unique that's what she said it's getting
into these change rooms like yeah can
you help me but can you help me use my
tampon no no no I think you should be in
Buffalo Bills well you think about this
objectivity though right like like again
and I don't say though is it to be a
rebuttal but I mean think about it's
actually worse I mean it's worse than
that
when you think of the practical
application of saying okay well hey I'm
gonna go to the women's restroom today
and later in the day I'm gonna go to the
men's restroom and then actually later
after that I'm gonna go back in the
women's restroom right in in all of the
places that for example I mean I I know
a number of women who actually consider
the women's restroom to be a safe space
right right so Rose whether is or it
isn't you're gonna take one person's
subjective view of a place where they
can go they can feel safe and
frankly if you've ever been in a woman's
restroom is always nicer than a men's
rush every time and now you're gonna say
opposite I've heard that it gets even
Messier it's it's messy but then they
start off really clean and nice
sometimes they have couches Oh often
have couches and flowers and scent
machines it's crazy couches yeah touches
that's disgusting yeah like you guys are
very porous it's very permeable mmm
clothes on that couch it's like if you
have a couch in a cigar lounge it's
always going to smell like that no
matter where you know you can sell it on
Craigslist it doesn't matter that's what
a white couch alright okay couch to the
bathroom will smell like time but my
butt but the idea being is that okay you
have a subjective view of what should be
what should be great and you're gonna
have these women who say the safe space
that I have them in the restroom to be
able to go there and not worry about men
being around and be able to you know cry
or to do my makeup or to do whatever I
adjust my dress now I have to say under
those rule under that yep pillow fight
we're lucky but now it just doesn't
matter right like yeah all the signs off
anyone google anywhere and this is
important because it's not based in
science at all gender is really it's
really more grammatical how was it we've
talked about this before Simone de
Beauvoir you go to the janmani study
right you get to Judith Butler they this
is a very new idea even people who
believe that gender was socially
constructed and separate from sex they
still only believed in two genders and
this is not scientifically based it was
never proven it's just theory it was
theory that was supposed to be talked
about in college because it didn't
really matter have real-world
consequences like most things that are
talked about in humanities courses and
then for some reason people weren't in
on the gag like let's just open up the
floodgates and even the professor's
themselves look what no it was a goof
goof so here's another reason by the way
with this bill target they're gonna be
targeting religious organizations
business owners the Equality Act
prohibits against any kind of
discrimination as they put it against
LGBTQ a EIP people from the bill any
establishment that provides a good a
service a program including a store
shopping center online retailer or
service provider salon we'll get back to
that Bank gas station food bank service
or care center shelter travel agency
funeral parlor or establishment that
provides health care accounting or legal
services they mentioned salon and
they're clearly because Jessica you need
was trying to get people to wax these
balls no like why this typically go so
they just say all business
well they also mentioned shelters right
so so battered women's shelters now have
to receive men right wouldn't going back
to a bill said that's another safe space
it literally is sometimes the only safe
place a lot ease will inhabited women
shelter and now we're gonna allow men
and which which is more trauma and
shelters and by the way a lot of
shelters are run by churches well I
shall run by religious organizations
these aren't people this is what's
important to note when we're talking
there's the letter of the law there's a
spirit of the law
people aren't creating battered women
shelters because they hate transgenders
they're trying to do good and then you
ruin it by saying it's not good enough
let's allow men there and people talk
about it let's get an example for a
church at our church status singles with
single moms night at our church this is
a big thing where single mothers would
go drop off their kids at daycare and I
think they would do like yoga or spin
class or sometimes would have like a
single like a matchmaking night with a
single man of the church so it would be
illegal for a church to say oh we're
having a single moms night here by the
way you have to be allowed if you're a
man yeah think about that for a second
who does that is that really about
equality again back to salons I just
it's so funny to me they're clearly
wanting to wax Jessica you Neves
testicles and scrotum yeah so so here's
one of the things that I do think that
that we all have to kind of keep in mind
on the on the conservative side in terms
of talking about these issues is really
if you get to the nub of what the why
this rule is around is because of the
few of the few examples of folks who are
treating other people in human humanely
right I mean there's one thing to say
jokes there's one thing to create a lot
criticize the political positions which
is what we're doing here and the
criticize I've been the application of
those rules it's another thing for
someone to say who's listening to this
to go out and say you know what I'm
gonna do every time I see someone who's
transgender I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm
gonna salt them I'm gonna I'm gonna
attack them in the workplace I'm gonna
discriminate again that's discriminate
against them in the workplace and treat
them in an inhumane way and that's
that's not what we're talking about
nothing about the actual practical
application comparing that comparing
that to know what you have a there's the
restroom is not treating them in an
inhumane way
well little girls in there and yeah now
every pushback becomes oh now you're a
hater now you're a hater now you hate
now you full of hate well this is how
far down we talk about slippery slope
look behind you
there's the slope because a bottom
other reason transitioning kids we've
talked about this quite a bit but a lot
of people don't know that the Equality
Act specifies that kids cannot be denied
people including kids cannot be denied
healthcare based on being transgender
we've already seen parents lose custody
of their children at a state level
because they refuse to pump them full of
hormones now you apply this federally
never mind that it's the right thing to
do we've talked most people don't think
you should allow kids to be put on
puberty blockers I think if anything
child services should take those parents
away if they start pumping a
seven-year-old boy full of estrogen yeah
but call me old-fashioned and this is
important to note by the way if the kids
don't transition we've talked about this
many times 75 to 90 percent of children
with gender dysphoria they completely
outgrow it with therapy they're put on
puberty blockers their percentage drops
to zero suicide attempted rate is still
42 percent the Equality Act will create
a federal legal basis for parents to
lose custody of their children for
denying them health care if they don't
go along with something that has what
there's no basis in science and we don't
have any data yet because this is really
really new we could be putting all these
kids into a shallow cancerous grave so
when you talk about loving when you talk
about caring about people listen you're
looking at a 42 percent suicide rate
you're looking at bone problems you're
looking at mood problems you're looking
at huge rates of depression and
schizophrenia like just telling someone
that they're perfect the way they are is
not compassion if a kid wants to eat
nothing but s'mores and in strawberry
preserves you tell them no because it's
probably not healthy for him that's the
case here if a kid wants to be put on
puberty blockers you say no why because
your bone plates have infused yet but I
don't want some lady in the white jacket
to come in here and take you away from
me so here's your estrogen pills there
you go want some cialis all right it's a
treat for everybody I don't assume the
kids would want cialis you can't block
him enough so anyone know Taylor the
Equality Act is not just basically we
all deserve equal rights under the law
it's like the green New Deal it's a
laundry list of leftist ideology that
completely tries to criminalize any
dissent and just like the green new deal
by the way the green New Deal takes over
pretty I don't want to say a fifth of
the economy because that's why we're
talking about health care the green New
Deal takes over all of the economy it
basically nationalizes energy and by the
way also shoehorns
social and racial justice in the green
why is this here what is this here black
again all right they are precious and it
said green isn't even in the song about
Jesus love you sure you have no basis
not even a fictional one so that
basically takes over the entire economy
nationally and now a bill like this the
Equality Act look it up yourself please
go read it check out our sources look
how loosely defined gender identity is
this would do for the social structure
the societal fabric of America what the
green New Deal would do for the economy
this takes control over all of it it
removes your control as a parent it
removes your control as a business owner
it removes your control as an athlete it
removes your control as someone who
wants to take a dump in peace without
Jessica and Eve coming in waxing his
scrotum and eat alright we have to go to
Tim Poole hopefully will will calm down
[Music]
- ooh Popeye little too hot we know you
used to be a little too far but it -
[ __ ] it with blood - Cristal
[Music]
my little - let's kill biggie smalls I
love you Michael
my little Tupac each sold separately
[Music]
trapezoid for you dance didn't that deep
in your headlined by Ernest gets
sodomized in prison that one wasn't cut
for time we just thought that was a
little rough yeah if you want me to read
another one of your letters use some
punctuation
lock it up let's go attempted robbery
that was thwarted by a [ __ ] guy in
the air vents
you think Epstein
would have been involved with like
actual human sacrifices at satanic
rituals absolutely right the people say
Biden makes gasps Biden is the gap is
like the dudes one hair plug away from
calling Trump president aft
[Music]
but it was just a vigilante [ __ ] and
now a reading from the Democratic
Socialist manifesto with comrade Cortez
it's become evidence that the
bourgeoisie is unfit any longer to be
the brilliant class squad is the ruling
class now we run this me a girl Ilhan
Rashida and I never learned the other
girl's name it doesn't matter
we're coming for you Israel join mug
club because soon videos like this will
be all that's left on YouTube
[Music]
I'm always curious about our next guests
dance moves because I found out that he
was biracial namely because he said he
was biracial yeah that was the only way
I could tell and then I thought well
maybe he was like you quarter black and
it turned out he was kind of Asian Oh
kind of Aidan like that sort of
Abercrombie ethnic works like I don't
know what it is but there's something
there that is not intimidating as a
white person it makes me want to buy you
know low-cut pants but I don't know what
their dancing is like so anyway you know
him you love him he's been in the show
multiple times we've done a devil's
advocate with him you follow his program
Tim cast on YouTube you can follow me on
twitter at tim cast he has an upcoming
live event Saturday August 31st with
mines IRL it's called ending racism
violence and authoritarianism mr. Tim
Poole how are you sir I'm pretty good
you know all things considered with the
event and all that yes okay well before
well I was going to ask you about living
in a van but we'll save that for later
yeah what do you mean all things
considered with the event for people who
don't know I gotta say man it has been a
stressful past couple of weeks we have
an event like you mentions called mines
IRL the overarching theme is ending
racism violence and authoritarianism
something I think you would probably
agree with all those things are bad I
would also agree pretty lofty goals for
one live event but but you know we want
to address the this cultural political
issue of the culture or whatever you
want to talk about and we tried our best
to bring in progressives and we have
many and some liberals as well as
moderates and conservatives I think it
leans more towards like the anti sgw
type but that's because those people are
so willing to get up on stage getting
progressives is difficult so much
tremendous respect to those progressives
who agreed to come and speak and sit
down right but we had this book so I'm a
sponsor my company subversive sponsoring
and I'm not one of the primary
organizers necessarily but I am speaking
as well we had this thing booked since
March contract signed good to go all
speakers publicly announced it is a
local event right by my house it's not
like I went to LA to put on this big
show mm-hmm within two weeks when we're
about to do this all of a sudden we
start getting this what I'm gonna call a
harassment campaign it's not a protest
it's a harassment campaign they're
calling local businesses they're calling
all of these different politicians in
the state and they're accusing us of
some of the weird
conspiracy insanity I've ever seen and
it's a couple there some semi hula I
want to call them local because they're
4050 miles away but they're these
progressive groups there's as well as an
anti-fog from New Jersey accusing the
group of let you name it you name it in
terms of the worst thing you can be and
it's it's there
white supremacy pedophiles you know the
Klan like all act like it's like they
reach into a hat and pulled out
buzzwords about what this is well here's
a thing two weeks out and we start
getting these harassing phone calls and
the theater tells us to GTFO and it's
the most insane thing ever that they
would that we would literally have an
event called ending racism week a couple
of the people are in the young turks
network who are speaking here that sound
like we're really bringing people
together so i'll tell you what really
scares me sanitizer what you don't
really scares me is oh yeah yeah but
what scares me is that this was a
legitimate attempt of following their
rules okay we've got more female
speakers than male we've got like 35
percent POC for like we did everything
they wanted us to do no a second you
said GTG TFO POC why are you naming cars
i'm not entirely
yeah the theater can't like they're
trying to cancel on us so we have a
backup venue but there's gonna be a
legal issue because we will not back
down look you can't have a contract for
4-5 months where you see the speakers
you know what the events about and then
bend the knee to crazy wacko far-left
conspiracy theorists who accuse us of
everything in the book man that's no
sense that's good quick question who's
you've mentioned today who's they i know
i read an article about an tyfa but are
they're organized groups like that have
publicly process to this or is it just
sort of happening in the dark portions
of the well they're there there's some
public they're not like huge but there's
a couple of groups like you want me to
name them i'd rather not
because i don't want to give them
attention okay you have to name them but
these are these are organized groups in
other words it's not just a random
person calling someone up because we've
talked about this where every now and
then you'll have someone at vox or
someone let you know along those lines
who complains of being harassed and it's
two people with a twitter egg versus an
organization or a concerted effort to
shut it down and you're saying it's the
latter there so so there is an anti
feliz mall handful of people in a
certain portion of
there's another group that claims to be
a progressive activist strip they have
photos of their meetings so it seems
like that's the case another group
actually has a very prominent activist
who's been featured in news stories so I
wouldn't call them famous
but they've you know they're they're not
um it's not like one or two people but
it might be fifteen or twenty I don't
know what they're doing is they're
rallying Democratic groups to send
harassing phone calls to local
businesses and it's gotten really bad
you know the theater called us in a
panic and I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm gonna
qualify the statement because of legal
issues but based on what I was told my
interpretation of the frantic and
panicked voice was that antifoam is
threatening to burn down their theater
this was corroborated by other people
and eventually came out in the press
that you know this guy was panics like
these people are crazy I can't you know
they're gonna burn the theater down all
the stuff something like that it may
have been that this guy was just
panicking and he saw some tweet which
was a joke but you know this frantic you
know flame and then we so we there have
been harassing phone calls that's
important to note though Tim I don't
want to skim over that because you live
in this world and I live in this world
you know for example with the Vox an
area that was going on where we're going
back and forth and I remember I had
someone who I worked with who will
remain nameless not someone here but
someone who you know it could have been
a hairstylist it could have been a
doctor let's put one of these sort of
contractors in my life and this person
said oh yeah I heard you got into a lot
of trouble with the gay community and I
said well on a second what are you
talking about Vox he had no idea he
thought it was the gay community people
who don't live in that world can much
more easily be intimidated so this
business owner the person who owns the
venue they're not reading Twitter all
the time they're not looking through
YouTube rebuttals and so the left they
like to use that intimidation they're
banking on them not knowing that it's
just an answer for group saying we're
gonna burn the house down because these
people who don't live in our universe
take it seriously and that's why we see
such severe ramifications when we go of
course this isn't legitimate they're
they're organizing protests they're
threatening violence like this is all
established and it's my neighborhood
it's within a few miles of my house
right and they're they're coming from
fifty to a hundred miles away calling it
self-defense
Internet isn't that is that mind-numbing
but I was gonna say earlier what's
what's scary about this to me is we
played by all of their rules
we got progressives wewe have more women
than men we did everything they asked of
us we have a headliner who is a person
of color famous anti-racist and they
still accuse us of being all right white
supremacists all of this nonsense and
you're right about these people who
aren't living in this world when they
get a phone call saying I'm going to
destroy your business and take your job
away
yeah they panic right then they start
hearing from their friends saying what's
going on you're having Nazis at your
venue and they're like no it's a lie
right but you know what when you get 50
phone calls to your business they start
putting fake reviews on your business to
smear you and slander you it has a real
impact on small businesses in a small
town sure you know for us I get smeared
all day every day I'm like whatever man
it's the Internet but for a local venue
so we actually have we have two venues
in Pittman New Jersey the theater gave
us the boot which they can't because we
have a contract but whatever we found
another venue but the VIP brewery has
defended us and you know they're the
ones who are getting the brunt of it now
because you know when the lies and the
slanders and the smears came in saying
it's Nazis and all that these people
actually did their due diligence instead
we talking about
yeah Young Turks guy who's gonna be
hanging out these people are not so well
we've we've always done that party it
shows reasonably we do after parties and
people can only get in if they have a
mug and we usually use cigar lounge is
because cigar lounge is tend to be
overwhelmingly conservative and it's
sort of counter cultural so a lot of the
owners they're like oh yeah just so you
know you can ask me like I don't give
they complain about this lounge just
because they don't like people smoking
on the sidewalk like that's a lot of
people say so in the future you might
want to look into it but this this this
brewery there they're like left-leaning
individuals one of the owners is you
know I don't want to speak on their
behalf to too far so I'll leave their
private life to their private life but
you know they're Democrats they're if
they're left-leaning they said free
speech is important they talked about
how you know what's really crazy and
I'll stress this point which is another
thing that's kind of worrying me is ten
months ago and coulter spoke at the same
theater and these some of these groups
didn't do anything I didn't care now all
of a sudden we're seeing like kind of a
dramatic escalation in a more liberal
event as being shot down but this
brewery they told me that when the
protests happen with Ann Coulter they
saw conservative
and proud boys and they thought hey this
is a great opportunity to start a
dialogue with some of these other groups
you know that was that was you know so
they they shared that kind of mentality
that conversation is better I think I
can tell you probably why that is they
assume that people are going to an Ann
Coulter's show are too far gone where
someone like you you're more moderate
you're making more inroads that's why we
get a lot of people who try to shut us
down before we do shows because they go
on a second this tends to be like a big
party on campus usually do a venue it's
a couple thousand seats it's more of a
comedy show some QA but it's a whole
production and it's not really the kind
of thing one should be protesting but
it's because they just don't want new
people to come to the show and I think
you're more likely to attract those
people then then Ann Coulter I want to
make sure they get this rep because I
wanna move on to another topic here
August 31st Saturday and where is the
show taking place I can't give the venue
up okay the last minute Bella Delft it's
in Philadelphia in the Philadelphia area
okay so well the website is IRL
minds.com and we're almost sold out so
IRL dot minds.com and I wanted to start
this and then we'll take it to the web
extended because we can always get in
trouble on YouTube for this so it seems
to me like you've been running up
against this quite a bit but you also
have some people saying well you play
both sides of the fence because you're
not really conservative you're not
really how would you identify yourself
because I know that you the one thing
you've been very straight on is you will
not vote for Donald Trump but you seem
to be butting heads with the left a
whole lot more than most on the right
well yeah I mean look there's a story
today in NBC where they claim Trump is
racist because he sent out an email
where he said they quote him it's our
country not theirs referring to Ocasio
cortez it's a lie it's a complete lie
what he was saying was the Electoral
College meat makes America for every zip
code not the coastal elites
it's our country not theirs right what
he was saying is the rich people they
they twist it to try to make him seem
racist but I read this and it's and it's
an over at ly so listen I you know I
look at someone like Tulsi Gabbard who I
really I really like she's defended free
species
she's denounced identity politics she
served her country recently even and
she's someone who aligns with a lot of
my values and she is defended free
speech for everybody including
conservatives so it really does work for
me in terms of someone I think would be
you know better than trumpet
as a commander-in-chief I think Trump
has personality defects which are bad in
terms of unification and I mean I think
one of the important aspects of the
president is being a charismatic leader
but then there's also foreign policy
things that I don't agree with and trust
me I criticize Obama all day every day
for ass foreign policy trip too and I
get I give Trump credit for his student
loan forgiveness for the veterans but
you know Trump is playing the Republican
angle and I die there's core principles
there I'm not gonna support but I don't
I don't hate Trump I just think he's
boorish and and rude but that's not you
know these are very light adjectives to
describe Donald Trump I think he's
somewhat off-color and but that being
said yeah I I also try to be I don't
know diplomatic right you know I
understand if I go to a trump supporter
it starts screaming about how Trump is a
nasty guy and like the worst in the
world it's gonna break apart our ability
to communicate yes so I need I need to
have respect for people who disagree
with me and and trying to understand
them and that's and that's a thing too
about the event we're hosting we have
Darrell Davis right here addict alized
quite a few caking former KKK members if
people don't know I haven't looked into
Terrell Davis there's a documentary out
there about him but his thing was give
them the respect they're asking for let
them express themselves and try and
understand them and that's that's a key
to to coming together and I completely
agree so you know I I I'm not a fan of
Trump but I'm not gonna go on my channel
and screech with with blood coming out
of my eyes about how he's a you know
he's Hitler so I'm like that is it
disrespectful of me to say that tulsi
gabbard is as easy on the eyes she's a
tall cool glass of water I don't think
so I mean I was asked that by Jesse
Kelly on his show and I was he was like
you know she said something that effect
and I'm like well she's a very
professional and beautiful woman and you
know you can't deny that but she's a
major in the National Guard man let's
you know that oh yeah I respect I
respect her service of course she has
kind of that nikki Haley vibe and I mean
that that's sort of that golden skin
dark hair very they always dress really
well and I don't just mean I just mean
she's hot I mean very well presented
women they put themselves together well
so I like that about tulsi gabbard don't
like her policies don't like the
platform but we'll talk about this more
a little bit on the web extended for
people who are listening we have to go
to break
if you're watching on YouTube this is
going to an extension now
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
did you enjoy tonight's open of course
you did you can thank the hundreds of
underage Chinese children animators
who've been working around the clock
solely for your amusement mug Club today
and maybe just maybe we can hire
American and let one of these little
tykes go to school since our last
livestream questions were left
unanswered did Elizabeth Warren scalp
Kamala Harris in the polls is Joe Biden
still alive will Bernie comb his hair
for these answers and more tune in
September 12th as we livestream the ABC
News Univision democratic debate it's
going to be the first live stream in the
new studio with your favorite guests the
lot of credit drinking game and a few
surprises
September 12th DNC debate be there hey
it's that time one live route of the
week first off thanks to our wonderful
sponsor Walter you can get the PPK now
actually made by Walter we appreciate
them our studios are protected by them
and of course the main sponsor of the
show is you not like PBS as viewers like
you we're really it's a federal
government it's actually viewers like
you we're not funded by a foreign
caliphate we don't get any subsidies
we're funded by mugs so join up at lot
of credit calm slash mug Club it's 99
dollars annually 69 for active military
students veterans listen I think a lot
of people out there like I appreciate
how many of you joined when we had the
Vox scenario going on you understand
that that's what's needed to sustain us
because there won't be anything on
YouTube at all if you don't join my club
but I think there's hours of content
that we could never upload to YouTube
that goes up every week daily shows that
you don't get here on YouTube so if you
want to support the show get that
content as well as access to the entire
blaze catalog join up at la doors credit
comm slash mug club change my minds and
confronts they don't come cheap but this
mug also doesn't come it's hand etched
and hands painted it's nice don't you
want to feel nice
[Music]
[Music]
that's the person who got to into his a
cuddly Suge Knight Ruxpin and then
drowned as a result oh he is heavy has a
lot of mechanical stuff remember always
deal with the most immediate problem
first if you're drowning your creature
comforts of home like your rucks it's
not it's not more important than not
drowning mmm we should watch out we
should either auction off the shook or
or reuse it buy though we do have
actually talking with Tim Poole there's
the extended web extended for people who
are not on my club much longer we
actually ate into politics quite a bit
but he's in that van we have we've
talked about it we have the super secret
crappy news van true that we have that
we started building and then we just
we're not going to be using it because
it's not big enough anymore we'll
probably auction it off at some point if
someone's looking for like a van life
we've updated the mechanics mechanical
issues in there beautiful carpet awful
it's red white and blue crushed velour
and it has the highest roof legally
allowable and it still can't go in a
parking garage so you could live in
there yeah thank you thank you so much
people of course watch supporter Crowder
confronts next week we have what do we
have going on next week no we have a
change I'm coming in yes two weeks two
weeks just a lot a lot going on so much
stuff this is we talked about this
during the I don't know if it was life
advice so we were talking about this
this week but I wanted to reiterate this
I heard someone talking about this the
other day saying you know this is a dark
period for our country and I hear that
talked about a lot and it's just a
comment that's really taken for granted
let's put politics away a little bit
okay and I never realize Anuj fan of
Barack Obama obviously we had a downturn
economy but right now genuine question
people out there even if you're not a
Trump fan the people out there like
what's-his-name Rick whatever whatever
the people at National Review the people
who were Republicans but hate Trump and
even Democrats do you really believe
this is a dark period in United States
history do you really believe that 10 15
50 years from now they'll be teaching
people that 2016 through 2019 was a dark
period for the United States I mean what
what wasn't was it a recession no
depression no unemployment no wars not
really where people being beaten in the
street lynched no crosses being burned
on lawns no
it's a may this is an amazing time in
history and as much as we bet things and
I know I get wound up about Taylor Swift
honestly this is an incredible time and
nobody appreciates it I want you to
genuinely look at your life right now
okay not just the United States but
let's think about the United States in a
historical perspective right now but I
also want you to think of your personal
life compare it to actual dark periods
right compared to the actual dark
periods in your life everyone has them I
can think of three or four and I think
of well not that one that was really
really tough so I want you to think of
that get in your head are you are you
still in a dark period unless apply that
same standard to the United States think
of an actual dark period of the United
States the Great Depression think of
World War two think of even have the
2008 crash unemployment was through the
roof think of 9/11
let's compare where we are now to an
actual dark period and by the way if
you're in a dark period personally
obviously create a plan take actions
take steps towards measurable progress
like we've talked about it's always the
same thing but if this isn't truly a
dark period right now can we just take a
moment to be grateful
this isn't inspiration this isn't
telling you what's it but just honestly
for a second right now what you think of
that dark period in your life what made
it dark what was so hard about it and if
it's not going on right now
say a prayer do some freaking gratitude
you might get in your head think about
it what is it was it a period where
maybe you're a relative had cancer was
it a period where maybe you couldn't
make ends meet was it a period where
maybe you were really sick and you were
struggling with chronic pain what
whatever it was if you were not going
through that right now even though you
have some other issues can you
acknowledge most of you out there that
they're probably not the worst because
we often pray or we ask for things and
then we don't either don't think that
will actually get them or we're not
grateful for them this is what happened
you know hopper is still doing well
hopper we thought I thought I was gonna
lose him he had cancer it was really a
severe chemos worked I know we're
probably not gonna have that much time
with him that's why I don't see him so
much in the show because I'll be honest
it just makes me kind of sad but Betty's
great
Betty's fantastic but that being said I
have to be grateful right now because
there was a period where we thought we
heard that he had lymphoma on Friday and
he would be gone by Tuesday and you know
what I have to sit and go hey it's been
a rough we
but that's not going on thank the Lord
we live in an amazing time in history in
an unbelievably blessed country so all I
want you to do here's the advice unless
you're in that truly dark period or you
can go back to the other crowd or closes
and we talk about how to get out of it
how does it a plan most of you aren't
though so if you're not in that truly
dark period and if you don't believe
that the United States is neat is in a
truly dark historical period the reason
I'm using dark periods because this is
what you hear in the media all the time
that term dark period in history if you
don't believe that to be the case do it
do everyone else's service walk around
with a smile on your face today and be
grateful be grateful internally and show
that you are grateful externally to the
people around you your life will be a
better place because it is awesome right
now despite not being perfect all right
I'll see you next week
[Music]